en este vídeo vamos a hablar del efecto
que tiene el control de precios en el
excedente total entre consumidores y
productores ya hemos hablado un poco de
esto en otros vídeos por ejemplo en el
vídeo sobre el control de rentas y en el
vídeo sobre el salario mínimo pero
tenemos que asegurarnos de comprender
bien los conceptos más importantes aquí
tenemos las clásicas curvas de oferta y
demanda para digamos el mercado sobre la
renta de departamentos a un precio alto
la cantidad demandada es baja y la
cantidad ofrecida es muy alta a un
precio bajo la cantidad ofrecida es baja
mientras que la cantidad demandada es
muy alta entre otros de nuestros vídeos
de economía vimos que el precio de
equilibrio y la cantidad de equilibrio
están en el punto donde estas dos curvas
o líneas se intersectan aquí vamos a
tener la cantidad q sub zero y aquí el
precio p sub zero supongamos que esta
gráfica describe al mercado de la renta
de departamentos de una ciudad y
supongamos que por alguna razón los
funcionarios municipales deciden que p
sub zero es demasiado alto la gente se
queja de que la renta es demasiado alta
en el mercado
entonces los funcionarios deciden poner
un control de precios en este caso
implementan un precio máximo dicen
de acuerdo el precio de la renta por mes
no puede sobrepasar este nivel ese es el
precio máximo y que va a suceder
entonces bueno si este es el precio
máximo esta es la cantidad total de
departamentos que los caseros y los
dueños de edificios están dispuestos a
ofrecer pero a este precio hay una
cantidad de demanda mucho mayor esta es
la cantidad demandada y cuando la
cantidad demandada a un precio
determinado es mayor que la cantidad
ofrecida tenemos escasez en el mercado
esta flecha describe la escasez ya
hablamos de esto en otros vídeos pero
veamos lo que pasa con el excedente
total cuando dejamos que el mercado
llegue a un precio y una cantidad de
equilibrio este es su excedente total
vamos a separarlo en excedente del
consumidor y excedente del productor y
ya hemos hablado de esto en otros vídeos
pero qué sucede cuando tenemos un
control de precios bueno esta es la
cantidad ofrecida pero de pronto el
excedente total se reduce ahora este
trapezoide blanco representa el
excedente total otro cambio que podemos
observar es que el 9
excedente del productor ella solo este
pequeño triángulo azul que está en la
parte inferior claramente todos los
productores se ven afectados y podríamos
decir por supuesto se trata de renta
controlada seguramente los consumidores
se beneficiarán de esto el caso es que
sólo algunos consumidores se
beneficiarán los que puedan entrar al
mercado de los departamentos se
beneficiarán pero no todos los
consumidores podrán hacerlo
principalmente porque lo que tenemos es
una escasez de departamentos antes de la
intervención del gobierno había más
gente que podía conseguir y ofrecer una
vivienda ahora estas personas no van a
poder conseguirla como en todo lo que se
refiere a economía los modelos
simplificados son muy útiles para
entender determinadas cosas pero debemos
ver con cierta reserva cualquier tipo de
modelo demasiado simplificado como éste
veamos porque de acuerdo con este modelo
el excedente del consumidor ha aumentado
para los consumidores que van entrando
al mercado parece que se están
beneficiando por ejemplo este consumidor
marginal o adicional antes obtenía todo
este beneficio y ahora puede obtener
también todo este pero piensen en las
cosas que este modelo no está tomando en
cuenta
es ahora el incentivo del casero que
tanto que reinvertir en el edificio tal
vez dejará que el edificio se deteriore
un poco existen particularidades
respecto a cómo se implementa la renta
controlada y éstas también pueden
cambiar el comportamiento de los agentes
que están en el mercado entonces siempre
hay que tener en mente que los modelos
no están tomando muchos factores en
cuenta pero en términos generales en
nuestro ejemplo hemos puesto un control
de precio en este caso un precio máximo
produce escasez en el mercado todos los
productores se van a ver afectados y
algunos consumidores se van a beneficiar
pero no todos ellos porque ahora no
todos los consumidores van a poder
encontrar una vivienda para rentar ahora
hablemos de otro mercado digamos el
mercado del maíz otra vez tenemos
nuestro precio de equilibrio y nuestra
cantidad de equilibrio este es el precio
de equilibrio pero supongamos que los
productores de maíz se organizan y
presionan al gobierno le dicen nosotros
nos vemos realmente afectados cuando los
precios del maíz son bajos por eso
queremos que se establezca un control de
precios
queremos un precio mínimo entonces el
gobierno dice
en productores de maíz parecen estar
hablando en serio así que voy a
instituir un precio mínimo al que se
venderá el maíz el precio no puede estar
por debajo de este nivel
este es un precio mínimo y que va a
suceder ahora pensemos en la cantidad
demandada y en la cantidad ofrecida esta
es la cantidad demandada que la gente
comprará vemos que el precio mínimo
establecido se intersecta con la curva
de demanda en este punto y esta es una
cantidad ofrecida que el precio mínimo
establece la curva de oferta se
intersecta con el precio mínimo en este
caso la cantidad demandada es menor que
la cantidad ofrecida y cuando esto
sucede tenemos un excedente en el
mercado los productores producen más de
lo que la gente quiere adquirir a ese
precio pensemos ahora en lo que pasa con
este excedente total en particular con
el excedente del consumidor y el
excedente del productor antes de la
intervención del gobierno éste era el
excedente del consumidor y este era el
excedente del productor ahora el
excedente total la suma de los dos
excedentes se ha reducido ahora este
trapezoide y podemos observar que todos
los consumidores se ven afectados
el excedente del consumidor se ha
reducido algunos consumidores ya ni
siquiera están consumiendo maíz e
incluso a los que lo consumen
por ejemplo este consumidor marginal o
adicional que antes obtenía todo este
beneficio ahora obtiene un menor
beneficio entonces podemos decir que
todos los consumidores se ven afectados
y qué pasa con los productores los
productores que puedan vender su maíz
definitivamente obtendrán un beneficio
por ejemplo este productor marginal
tiene todo este excedente pero ahora
podrá obtener un precio más alto por él
entonces una manera de plantearlo es que
de acuerdo con este modelo algunos
productores se beneficien pero es
importante entender que no todos los
productores se beneficien porque tenemos
excedente y tendremos muchos productores
que ni siquiera podrán vender su maíz a
ese precio esta es una cuestión
interesante en la que vale la pena
reflexionar siempre hay que ver con
cierta reserva estos modelos pero son un
marco adecuado para entender ciertos
conceptos o entender situaciones que
pueden suceder cuando los gobiernos
toman decisiones a la ligera para tratar
de hacer que algo luzca bien o para
atrás
a los contribuyentes el efecto final de
estas decisiones puede ser que la gente
termine más afectada de lo esperado
porque imponer un precio máximo puede
generar escasez e imponer un precio
mínimo puede generar excedente nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo